another trip to the DC courthouse for
former president Donald Trump facing
four felony charges for attempting to
overturn the 2020 election his attorneys
trying to convince three appella judges
that he is immune from prosecution
because although he was impeached over
his actions on January 6th he was not
convicted by the US Senate the judges
seemed skeptical I asked you a yes no
yes or no question could a president who
ordered Seal Team s to assassinate a
political rival who was not
impeached would he be subject to
criminal prosecution if he were
impeached and convicted first and so so
your answer is is my answer is qualified
yes prosecutor called that
extraordinarily frightening arguing it
would allow future presidents to commit
a raft of crimes and in fact during the
Senate's impeachment trial Trump's own
lawyers argued that he shouldn't be
impeached because he could later be
charged and some senators agreed we have
a criminal justice system in this
country we have civil
litigation and former presidents are not
immune from being accountable by either
one Trump didn't need to appear in
person but he has been able to use his
court cases to increase his fundraising
by claiming he's being politically
persecuted they feel this is the way
they're going to try and win and that's
not the way it goes that'll be bedum in
the country it's a very bad thing it's a
very bad precedent whatever the Appeals
decides it will likely be appealed to
the US Supreme Court and some legal
analysts say that is likely the point
Trump is absolutely trying to drag this
out as long as possible in the hope that
if he's elected he can make all of this
go away if he were to be elected all the
prosecutions would immediately stop
because there is case law providing that
you can't prosecute you can't have a a
uh criminal trial of a sitting president
now the outcome of this case is
significant not just for Donald Trump
and his future but for the presidential
election
in a recent poll 24% of his supporters
said that if he is convicted in this
case his name should not be on the
ballot in a close election a number that
big could matter Patty khaine Al jazer
Washington make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer